ryder's republic from ubisoft
standing on the stage got the whole
place rocking it's popping no stopping
hey man i've been hearing a lot about
you playing lots and lots of potential
hansuki by the way it's been years
competing at the highest level
what i discovered is that there's so
much more to the republic than meets the
eye so that adventure exploration and
connecting with the outdoors on a whole
new level
[Music]
this place is called the writer's ridge
it's the heart and soul of the republic
team up with friends other riders and
compete against each other
[Music]
it's up to you to prove your worth in
the republic
take on sponsored events or pit yourself
against other riders in the biggest most
competitive mass races
as the winds roll in you'll attract
bigger sponsors better gear and earn
your spot among the best riders the
ridge community has to offer
i really like to introduce you to
someone this is brett he's kind of a big
deal bike ski wingsuit legendary status
in all three
he's always looking for riders who have
the potential to become champions
okay sparky
if you can show me you've got what it
takes then i'm willing to give you a
shot
[Music]
it's now time for you to win more than
gold
don't worry
we got your back
now go get em
you